Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zu Nummer 67 hier in der Reihe unserer Gespräche über Wissenschaft, über Forschung, andere Interessante Einblicke in die Welt
und wie wir sie denn zu verstehen haben.
Und heute wollen wir mal ja mal einen ganz anderen Blickwinkel einnehmen, würde ich sagen, den wir so in der Form noch nicht gehabt haben.
Und wollen uns mal die Forschung in einem politischen Bereich anschauen, ganz konkret die Forschung zur Sicherheitspolitik
und konkreter uns mit so Fragen beschäftigen, die man vielleicht ganz grob als digitale Repression zusammenfassen könnte.
Sprich, was machen Staaten und ähnliche Strukturen mit den Menschen, jetzt wo die Welt sich zunehmend digitalisiert
und was haben diese neuen Infrastrukturen, die wir jetzt alle täglich benutzen für einen Einfluss auf diese Machtstrukturen, die damit verbunden sind.
Und dazu begrüße ich meine Gesprächspartnerin, nämlich Anita Gohdes, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Frau Gohdes, Sie sind Professorin an der Hertie School of Governance, und zwar Abteilung, wie nennt sich das?
Cybersecurity ganz modern.
Genau, ich bin Teil des Centers for international security policy.
Jetzt relativ neu gegründet an der Hertie School of Governance.
Relativ neu heißt wann?
Ich glaube, uns gibt es offiziell seit 2016, aber wir sind jetzt erst gerade dabei, uns langsam zu etablieren.
Ich bin erst seit Februar jetzt an der Hertie School.
Okay.
Das heißt, wir sind noch im Wachsen.
Dampft noch.
Genau.
Schön. Aber das war ja nicht Ihre erste Haltestelle in diesem Thema, nehme ich mal an.
Wie kommt man denn überhaupt dazu, sich mit Politikwissenschaft zu beschäftigen?
Also mein Studium war im Bereich Politikwissenschaft, also mein erstes Studium, der Bachelor, war im Bereich Politikwissenschaft, Verwaltungswissenschaft.
Da habe ich mich schon sehr für das Thema internationale Beziehungen interessiert.
Warum?
Ja.
Soll ich da jetzt zurückgehen in meine Familiengeschichte?
Wenn es da Einblicke gibt, würde ich das gerne hören.
Warum macht man das?
Ja, ich glaube, das Thema interessiert viele Studierende, einfach weil internationale Politik heutzutage einen direkten Effekt auf unser tägliches Leben hat.
Wir leben in Deutschland, Deutschland ist ein Teil der EU, Deutschland ist Teil vieler internationaler Organisationen.
Und das sind einfach Dinge, die uns natürlich jeden Tag beschäftigen.
Na gut, aber es würde ja nicht jeder automatisch auch studieren wollen deswegen.
Genau, aber mich, glaube ich, hat es schon sehr stark geprägt, dass meine Familie einen sehr internationalen Hintergrund hat.
Meine Eltern sind aus Südafrika, sind Ende der 70er nach Deutschland gekommen.
Und ich glaube, diese Mischung des Hintergrundes, südafrikanisches, deutsch, zwei Länder mit extrem autokratischer repressiver Vergangenheit im 20. Jahrhundert hat mein Denken,
was staatlichen Machtmissbrauch und Repression angeht, sehr stark beeinflusst.
Beeinflusst, ja okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Ja, ich denke, wenn man so ein bisschen polyglotter aufgestellt ist schon familiär, dann kommt vieles von dem auch mehr oder weniger automatisch.
Genau, also 94, als Nelson Mandela gewählt wurde und meine Mutter mich stundenlang vorm Fernseher damit getrietzt hat,
diese Amtseinführung zu schauen, das hat, glaube ich, schon einen sehr starken Effekt auf meine politische Sozialisierung gehabt.
Naja, mit acht Jahren denkt man natürlich nicht drüber nach, dass das jetzt so wichtig wäre, aber jetzt bin ich natürlich sehr glücklich.
Getrietzt?
Aber sie fand es wichtig?
Sie fand es extrem wichtig.
Okay und positiv.
Und ich jetzt auch, ja natürlich.
Also musste das dann auch studiert werden?
Naja, ich habe mich eben früh dafür interessiert und vor allem eben für die Frage, inwiefern staatliche Institutionen ihre Macht missbrauchen.
Also ich glaube, das hat mich seit Beginn meines Studiums an extrem interessiert.
Dann habe ich meinen Master gemacht im Bereich Menschenrechte tatsächlich.
Und habe da schon versucht, ich habe mich immer für Mathematik und für Sozialwissenschaft interessiert,
nicht Richtung Menschenrechte, aber eben mit einem Fokus auch auf datenstatistische Auswertungen zu konzentrieren.
Vor zehn Jahren gab es da noch nicht so viele Programme, ich habe das in Essex studiert, in England.
Das war einer der Programme, die eben Statistik mit Menschenrechten kombiniert haben, war noch ein bisschen exotisch damals.
Ja.
Jetzt, zehn Jahre später, wo viele Leute über Data for Good und diese ganzen Geschichten reden, ist das überhaupt nicht mehr so ungewöhnlich.
Und das finde ich eine supertolle Entwicklung.
Also das zu sehen, dass sich jetzt einfach viel mehr Menschen dafür interessieren, wie man Daten für gute Zwecke benutzen kann
oder eben auch, um kritische Sachverhalte aufzudecken, das freut mich natürlich.
Das hießt, von Essex ging es dann direkt nach Berlin oder?
Nein, von Essex ging es dann für ein Jahr in die USA und da habe ich dann zum ersten Mal wirklich an dem Thema Menschenrechte und Statistik gearbeitet.
Und habe da erst ein Praktikum gemacht und dann gearbeitet für die Human Rights Data Analysis Group.
Das ist eine Nichtregierungsorganisation, die in San Francisco sitzt und sich primär damit beschäftigt, statistische Auswertungen von Menschenrechtsverletzungen zu machen.
Originär für Wahrheitskommissionen, für NGOs, die versuchen, in repressiven Ländern oder Konfliktländern Daten zu sammeln und auszuwerten.
Oder zum Beispiel auch für internationale Organisationen.
Human Rights Data Analysis Group.
Genau.
Habe ich auch noch nie gehört.
Aha, seit 2002.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt, hier ist das Ziel, auf Basis von Daten Wahrheit zu bilden?
Ist das so ein bisschen der Vorläufer des Factcheckings, wie wir es heute kennen?
Die Idee ist ein bisschen, die statistischen und wissenschaftlichen Tools, die wir haben, dafür zu nutzen, Machthaber zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen.
Also das, würde ich sagen, ist ganz plakativ der Slogan, also wirklich speaking truth to power oder having evidence based arguments, wie man auf Englisch sagen würde.
Also faktenbasierte Argumente zu haben.
Weil man eben häufig in Konfliktgebiete oder gerade nach großen Konflikten das Problem hat, dass man beweisen will, welche Seite den Großteil der Schuld auf sich nehmen sollte.
Und diese statistischen Analysen können eben helfen im Kontext von zum Beispiel Gerichtsverfahren zu sagen,
wenn wir uns die Muster anschauen, alle registrierten Daten, die wir haben, über Menschen, die gestorben sind,
und wir hier wirklich gute Informationen darüber haben, wer die Täter waren, dann können wir sagen, dass ein Großteil der Täter zum Beispiel staatlicher Seite war oder nicht staatliche Seite war.
Und umgekehrt können wir sagen, die Muster, die wir sehen, bezüglich wer zum Beispiel umgebracht wurde, zeigen uns, dass es ganz klar gewissen Gruppen gab,
die mehr attackiert wurden als andere.
Ja. Wollen wir da mal ein Beispiel nehmen, was da bei der HRDAG so angefasst wurde?
Also ich glaube, eins der wichtigsten Beispiele ist Guatemala.
Ja.
Das war vor meiner Zeit.
Das sind Projekte, die meine Kollegen bearbeitet haben und da ging es eben ganz klar darum, beweisen zu wollen, dass die Menschen oder die Menschen in Guatemala, die umgebracht wurden,
nicht einfach zufällig willkürlich ausgewählt wurden, sondern dass es einen ganz klaren Fokus darauf gab, Menschen mit indigenem Hintergrund ins Visier zu nehmen.
Und das haben diese Analysen eben zeigen können.
Und natürlich ist das nur ein kleiner Teil von so einem Gerichtsverfahren.
Aber wo holt man dann die Daten her?
Die Daten holt man sich so gut es geht von ganz vielen verschiedenen Quellen.
Also die Idee ist quasi, so viele Quellen wie möglich zu benutzen und diese miteinander statistisch zu verbinden,
um nachher ein statistisches Argument zu bauen, was, egal wer es sich anschaut, egal welcher Wissenschaftler nachher versucht, diese Methoden quasi nachzuvollziehen,
sagt, na das macht Sinn, das sieht nach einem sehr konservativen Argument aus und das sollte dann die Menschen im Gericht überzeugen.
Na gut, aber dann muss man auch mit den Quellen überzeugen.
Ja.
Deswegen frage ich gerade, wie sicher, also dann hängt ja sozusagen alles daran, dass die Quellen …
die Quellen müssen ja schon mal wasserfest sein.
Genau, die Quellen müssen …
Wenn es jetzt die Daten aber insofern gar nicht gibt oder es gibt sie immer und man muss nur an der richtigen Stelle gucken?
Was für Quellen sind da genommen worden?
Also zum einen muss man sagen, man kann diese Art von Arbeit, die wir machen, nicht in jedem Konflikt machen.
Es gibt Konflikte, die haben extrem wenig Information, es gibt extrem wenige Menschen, die vor Ort Informationen sammeln.
Und in diesen Situationen können wir keine statistischen Analysen machen.
Das heißt, es gibt schon eine gewisse Vorauswahl.
Und was war das jetzt? Dann wahrscheinlich in Guatemala?
In Guatemala gab es extrem viele verschiedene Organisationen nichtstaatliche Organisationen, zum Beispiel kirchliche Organisationen.
In vielen Ländern sind es Gewerkschaften, die solche Daten sammeln.
Manchmal sind es aber auch die Ombudsstellen von Regierungen, von subnationalen Regierungen.
Manchmal ist es auch so, dass vor Ort NGOs, internationale NGOs Daten sammeln, zum Beispiel das Rote Kreuz sammelt oft Daten, die UN sammelt Daten.
Und ich glaube, man unterschätzt, in wie vielen Konflikten eigentlich solche Daten gesammelt werden.
Die sind natürlich nie komplett, und deswegen ist unsere Aufgabe dann als Statistiker, diese Daten zusammenzubringen.
Die dann zusammenzubringen und sozusagen in ein neues Bild zu bringen?
Ja.
Das ist ja schon mal eine ganz interessante Perspektive, die habe ich jetzt so auch noch nicht gehabt.
Dass sozusagen NGO-Tätigkeit, natürlich nicht nur, aber dann eben auch nicht nur davon definiert ist, wir müssen jetzt Leuten Wasser geben, Häuser zugänglich machen, was weiß ich,
juristische Beratung leisten, alles wichtige Tätigkeiten, sondern auch, wir müssen erfassen, wir müssen Daten sammeln, wir müssen wirklich konkret das beschreiben, was wir sehen
und möglichst in einer gut zu verwertenden Form vorrätig halten, veröffentlichen, weiterreichen, absichern etc..
Ja.
Also es geht im ganz großen Sinne um Rechenschaft, es geht um Rechenschaft.
Und eine Sache, die wir, egal in welchem Konflikt wir gearbeitet haben, immer wieder von normalen Zivilisten gehört haben, ist,
wie wichtig es ihnen ist zu sagen, meine Mutter, mein Vater, mein Bruder ist gestorben, ich möchte, dass das für die Nachwelt festgehalten wird.
Und ich möchte, dass dieser Name irgendwo erscheint und ich möchte, dass diejenigen, die dafür verantwortlich sind, zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden.
Das kann man natürlich jetzt nicht, man sollte das nicht aufwerten mit anderen Tätigkeiten, die internationale Organisationen oder lokale Organisationen machen,
aber ich glaube, man darf nicht unterschätzen, wie wichtig dieses Rechenschaftsargument für viele Menschen, die eben in diesen Situationen sind, sind.
Das heißt, diese Human Rights Data Analysis Group, um jetzt nochmal kurz bei diesem Beispiel zu bleiben, damit es ein bisschen plastischer wird,
ist jetzt in Guatemala losgegangen, ich weiß nicht, was ist da genau vorgefallen, was war jetzt der Konflikt der konkrete?
Es gab einen langen Bürgerkrieg in Guatemala.
Ich bin jetzt kein Spezialist für Guatemala.
Ja.
Und es ging eben ganz klar danach darum zu sagen, wir müssen vorrangig die massive Gewalt, die von staatlicher Seite ausgeübt wurde,
für die müssen die Menschen, die dafür verantwortlich waren, zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden.
Und dazu muss man analysieren, was überhaupt passiert ist.
Und dazu müssen wir quasi analysieren, was passiert ist.
Weil es natürlich immer in jedem Konflikt und ich meine, das ist schon lange vor Digitalisierung ein Thema gewesen, eine gewissen Narrative gibt,
die von Seiten der Regierung, von Seiten von nichtstaatlichen Organisationen gesponnen wird.
Und dieser Narrative harte Fakten entgegenzustellen, ist eben eine Aufgabe, die wir mit Statistik versuchen zu bedienen.
Ich musste eben schon so ein bisschen zucken.
Also ja. Mathematik hat mich interessiert und Politikwissenschaft.
Das sind ja jetzt so zwei Felder, die man jetzt nicht unbedingt als erstes in unmittelbaren Zusammenhang bringen würde, abgesehen davon, dass man natürlich Mathematik mit allem in Zusammenhang bringen kann,
aber wird langsam klar, was hier sozusagen dahintersteckt.
Weil nur Daten zu haben an sich, ist ja erst mal kein Wert.
Also wenn man all das jetzt einsammelt, man hat halt Berichte, weil die sind ja nicht alle vergleichbar, die haben nicht alle dieselbe Struktur,
die haben nicht alle dieselbe Mächtigkeit, die sagen über unterschiedliche Dinge irgendetwas aus,
das heißt, man kann sie auch nicht ohne weiteres miteinander in Korrelation bringen.
Was für Modelle muss man denn dann ins Feld bringen?
Also ist das dann wirklich viel Handarbeit oder gibt es da tatsächlich etablierte Methoden der Statistik oder irgendeiner anderen mathematischen Subdisziplin,
wie man an so was rangeht?
Also erst mal muss ich eine Lanze brechen für meine Disziplin, die Politikwissenschaft, weil ich glaube, es wird häufig unterschätzt,
wie viel unsere Arbeit tatsächlich quantitativ mit statistischen Methoden ist.
Also es ist natürlich nur ein Teil der Politikwissenschaft, aber die Sozialwissenschaften allgemein haben in den letzten,
ich würde sagen, 30-40 Jahren einen enormen Boom an, sagen wir mal, Statistikmethodikdaten gesehen und wir eben auch sehen,
dass ganz viele der Fragen, die wir haben, eigentlich sich viel besser oder auch sehr gut mit Daten…
Das hat immer so ein bisschen den Nimbus des Reininterpretierens und Meinen und so weiter.
Genau, und es gibt eben schon sehr lange sehr etablierte sozialwissenschaftliche Felder und vor allem Universitäten, die sich darauf spezialisieren, Menschen so auszubilden.
Das hat früh angefangen mit der Wahlforschung, da hat man früher gesagt, naja, wir zählen ja, wie viele Menschen irgendwo gewählt haben und für wen sie gewählt haben,
da können wir jetzt schon früh mit Statistik ansetzen.
Ja.
Aber jetzt auch gerade im Bereich Konfliktforschung, Sicherheitsforschung, in dem ich aktiv bin, hat sich seit den 80er Jahren enorm viel getan
und viele Programme haben sich komplett darauf spezialisiert zu sagen, wir müssen verstehen, was in Konflikten passiert,
und zwar sind qualitative Studien extrem wichtig, aber es ist eben auch nur ein Teil und der andere Teil kann eben auch abgedeckt werden, indem wir versuchen, wirklich Daten zu sammeln
über verschiedene Aspekte von Frieden und Konflikt.
Aber wie geht man jetzt ran, wenn man da so ein absolut inhomogenes Feld von Datenquellen hat?
Da muss man dann erst mal irgendeinen Plan machen oder muss man irgendwie erst mal losstrategisieren, wie man da jetzt rangeht.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also in dem Bereich, in dem ich aktiv bin, also wo es wirklich um die Frage von Menschenrechtsverletzungen geht, verwenden wir eigentlich ein relativ einfaches Schema
und das nennt sich das who did what to whom Schema, also wer hat wem was angetan Schema.
Und da geht es eben einfach darum zu sagen, wir versuchen jetzt erst mal, alle Informationen, die wir haben, auf die Ebene der individuellen Verletzung runterzubrechen.
Warum machen wir es auf Verletzungsebene und nicht auf Individualebene?
Weil eine Person im Laufe seines Lebens oder ihres Lebens viele verschiedene Verletzungen erleben kann.
Und die können von verschiedenen Tätern kommen.
Die können im Kontext mit anderen Menschen zusammen passieren und deswegen gehen wir eben nicht auf die Ebene des Individuums, sondern auf die Ebene der Verletzungen.
Vorfalls.
Und dann versuchen wir eben, für jeden Vorfall festzustellen, wer war der oder die Täterin?
In welchem Kontext ist es passiert?
Wo und wann?
Und wenn wir dann noch andere Informationen darüber haben, wie genau es passiert ist, durch welche äußeren Umstände,
wieviele Menschen das gesehen haben zum Beispiel, dann hilft uns das natürlich weiter.
Aber erst mal sind wir nur daran interessiert, Zeit, Ort, Name und dann, wenn es geht, auch noch Informationen über den oder die Täterin zu bekommen.
Und dann hat man schon mal …
Und den Kontext, sagten Sie gerade.
Also wie fasst man Kontext?
Was könnte ein Kontext sein?
Kontexte können verschiedene Sachen sein, also Kontext kann zum einen sein …
Also jetzt im Rahmen welchen Konfliktes oder in der Art und Weise wie dieser Vorfall abgelaufen ist?
Das kann beides sein.
Je nachdem was für die Fragestellung, die man hat, wichtig ist.
Also meistens gehen wir natürlich schon von einer Fragestellung aus.
Die Fragestellung kann zum Beispiel sein, wir wollen wissen, ob es im Laufe eines Konfliktes zu einer Verschlimmerung der Situation kam.
Und dann wollen wir natürlich vor allem die temporale Ebene bedienen und wissen, wann was passiert ist.
In anderen Konflikten geht es uns gar nicht da viel darum, ob es jetzt 2001 oder 2002 passiert ist, sondern wir wollen wissen, wo es passiert ist.
Weil uns das was darüber sagt, welche Gruppe da zum Beispiel aktiv war.
Aber haben denn diese Datenquellen, von denen wir vorhin gesprochen haben, dann auch schon diese Struktur und Qualität oder ist das etwas, was man dann mühsam dem noch hinzufügen muss?
Es ist sehr viel Arbeit, das muss man auf jeden Fall sagen und es variiert enorm.
Und ich glaube, wenn wir nachher noch auf die Frage der Digitalisierung zu sprechen kommen, hat sich das … also es gab wirklich eine absolute Revolution, würde ich sagen,
im Bereich der Art, wie Daten gesammelt werden in Konflikten.
Das heißt, das hat sich rumgesprochen, dass das sozusagen ein wichtiger Faktor ist?
Naja und ich meine, heutzutage ist es einfach viel einfacher für Menschen, die ein Handy haben, die einen Laptop haben, die Freunde haben, die ein Handy haben, detaillierte Informationen festzuhalten.
Mal ein Bild festzuhalten von der Situation.
Ja.
Das ist ganz anders als es früher war.
Gibt es da auch so richtig Apps dann in der Hinsicht, um solche Vorfälle zu lernen?
Also Apps gab es schon recht früh.
Ja.
Also im Kontext der Human Rights Data Analysis Group wurde recht früh eine App entwickelt,
die versucht hat, Menschen zu helfen, diese Daten zu sammeln.
Da kommt natürlich jetzt auch die Sicherheitsfrage ins Spiel.
Es gab in den letzten Jahren einen Boom von Leuten, die gedacht haben, sie können Apps bauen, um Menschenrechtsdokumentation zu verbessern.
Einige machen sehr gute Arbeit, andere sind natürlich extrem sicherheitsanfällig und machen die Situation vielleicht für die Menschen, die diese App nachher auf ihrem Handy haben, noch viel gefährlicher.
Ja.
Das heißt, man sollte da nicht einfach leichtfertig drangehen und irgendwie denken, dass man mit Technologie leicht lösen und beliebig beschleunigen kann.
Beliebig beschleunigen kann. Ja.
Okay gut, aber zumindest ist es klar, dass quasi Daten sind wichtig, um Menschenrechtsverletzungen überhaupt zu erfassen, zu bewerten und dann vor allem im Nachgang zu bewerten,
um dem dann sozusagen auch eine juristische oder eben auch moralische Bewertung hinzufügen zu können.
Manchmal kommt es ja nicht zu mehr als das.
Ja.
Und man muss das so sehen, dass es halt in zunehmendem Maße fester Teil dieser Tätigkeiten ist
und dass das auch über alle Gruppen, die sich in irgendeiner Form in diesem Feld bewegen,
sei es so was wie Rote Kreuz medizinisch oder eben konkrete andere Menschenrechtsaktivisten, dann gleichermaßen betrifft.
Genau, und ich glaube, also ich möchte jetzt hier auch nochmal klar sagen, dass wir unsere Arbeit immer als Teil eines größeren Menschenrechtsprojektes sehen.
Also wir haben in vielen Konflikten mit zum Beispiel Human Rights Watch oder Amnesty zusammengearbeitet,
wo Amnesty und Human Rights Watch natürlich die Kontextperspektive haben und auch die Expertise haben
und ich glaube, wir machen dann die stärksten Argumente, wenn wir wirklich eine Kombination haben aus Experten für den Konflikt aus juristischer Perspektive
und dann eben auch aus statistischer Perspektive.
Und ich glaube, das sind dann die Situationen, wo man wirklich Reports und Argumente hat, die schwer sind, einfach von der Hand zu weisen.
Wenn ich das jetzt also richtig sehe, ist jetzt Ihre aktuelle Tätigkeit jetzt an der Hertie School oder sagen wir mal, die Arbeit in den letzten Jahren,
vielleicht unabhängig auch von dem Ort, ist spezifisch spezialisiert auf die neuen Herausforderungen der Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft?
Ja.
Und dann eben auch konkret auf diese Auswertung.
Wie hat sich das dann weiterentwickelt?
Ich meine, jetzt haben wir ja gerade noch von der Zeit in den USA gesprochen, jetzt sind schon wieder ein paar Jahre vergangen
und das Thema ist ja nicht geringer geworden.
Welche Methoden werden jetzt sozusagen ins Auge gefasst?
Was kann jetzt hier noch verbessert werden oder woran wird gerade gearbeitet?
Also ich habe dann, nachdem ich in Kalifornien war, habe ich dann in Mannheim promoviert.
Mannheim ist eben so eine sozialwissenschaftliche Hochburg, die sich stark mit quantitativen Analysen beschäftigt.
Und ich glaube, in dem Bereich …
Also Universität in Mannheim?
Universität, genau, Mannheim, nicht die Stadt Mannheim.
Ja, wer weiß.
Manchmal bildet sich da ja auch noch so eine Traube drum herum.
Genau, genau.
Und ich glaube, in dem Bereich hat sich enorm viel getan.
Also einfach dieses Bewusstsein dafür, dass diese neuen technologischen Möglichkeiten, die wir haben, die neuen Daten, die da hervorspringen,
auch für, wie es ganz plakativ, for good, genannt wird, für gutes benutzt werden kann,
das hat sich wirklich also exponentiell verändert.
Meistens zum Guten, ich glaube, wie ich eben schon angesprochen habe, kann es natürlich auch dazu führen,
dass übertriebener Aktionismus nicht unbedingt dann wirklich auch zu Verbesserung führt.
Aber, ich glaube, dieses Bewusstsein hat dazu geführt, dass auch viele Statistiker, viele Menschen, die vorher vollkommen nur im Bereich Informatik gearbeitet haben,
eben jetzt auch verstanden haben, dass ihre Expertise über ihr eigentliches Fach hinaus gefragt ist und eben auch viel verändern kann.
Und wir sehen eine enorme Nachfrage gerade bei vielen Studierenden, die eben sagen, ich habe jetzt diese Skills, ich möchte damit jetzt aber auch was gutes machen.
Ich möchte nicht einfach nur irgendwo arbeiten, wo meine Arbeit untergeht und wo sie vielleicht gar keinen Unterschied macht.
Oder Brücken berechnen oder so.
Ich würde sagen, Brücken berechnen ist wahrscheinlich noch … /lacht/
Okay /lacht/, also nicht nur Brücken berechnen.
… ein sehr wichtiger Bereich.
Aber viele sagen zum Beispiel, ich möchte jetzt nicht einfach nur einen Algorithmus optimieren, damit noch bessere Werbung jemandem angezeigt wird.
Ja okay.
Sondern ich möchte irgendwie …
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel.
… ich möchte die Welt verändern.
Das sagen natürlich viele und das ist natürlich super für die Community, die sagt, wir möchten in dem Bereich irgendwie auch wirklich vorwärts streiten.
Wir können natürlich keine kompetitiven Gehälter zahlen, die vielleicht andere Firmen zahlen können, aber bei uns gibt es Sinn.
Ja okay, die Sozialwissenschaften stehen ja, finde ich, schon so ein bisschen immer im Schatten so der Bedeutung, die man ihr zumisst.
Gerade im Vergleich zu Naturwissenschaft.
Mathematik mag da noch ein bisschen separat stehen, das versteht immer keiner, aber alle wissen, dass es irgendwie wichtig ist, weil die andern alle das sagen,
dass sie das auch brauchen.
Aber vielleicht führt das ja hier sozusagen auch zu einer Aufwertung des Feldes selbst.
Ich glaube, wir sehen eine enorme Nachfrage nach Sozialwissenschaftlern gerade.
Und viele meiner Kollegen kriegen jetzt Jobangebote von großen Techfirmen, die eben sagen, wir haben jetzt irgendwie festgestellt, wir haben diese Probleme
und siehe da, wir können sie nicht nur durch Technologie lösen, wir brauchen tatsächlich Menschen, die die Schnittstelle verstehen.
Und das sehe ich eben auch bei meinen Studierenden, dass sie eben sagen, viele der Probleme, die wir heutzutage haben, in Bezug auf die Digitalisierung,
sind Probleme, die können wir nicht nur durch Technologie oder durch Politik ändern, sondern das müssen Menschen sein, die beides verstehen.
Und ich glaube, das haben viele der großen Technologiefirmen jetzt auch verstanden.
Zum ersten Mal sieht man jetzt eben, dass die Industrie sich eben auch …
oder was heißt zum ersten Mal, aber man sieht, dass die Industrie sich jetzt verstärkt für die Arbeit von Sozialwissenschaftlern in diesem Bereich interessiert.
Ein ähnlicher Bereich, der sich ja sozusagen dem Datenmaterial vor einigen Jahren mehr geöffnet hat in meiner Wahrnehmung, ist ja der Journalismus.
Die auch gesehen haben, auch Berichterstattung ist ja letztlich auch eine Interpretation sozialer gesellschaftlicher Zustände.
Ja.
Also man muss ja jetzt nicht immer unbedingt den Fokus Menschenrechte haben und immer nur von den Vollkatastrophen ausgehen,
sondern generell die Bewertung von, was findet eigentlich statt in der Politik, was findet eigentlich statt in der Gesellschaft?
Wo drücken sich Mehrheiten aus?
Was sind sozusagen erkennbare Phänomene und wie kann man die eben auch quantitativ fassen?
Ja.
Und daraus dann wiederum Schlüsse ziehen.
Ist das nicht eigentlich sehr nahe beieinander?
So die Idee des Datenjournalisten auf der einen Seite und eben dieser generelle statistische Ansatz für eine sozialwissenschaftliche Betrachtung?
Ich glaube, schon, ja. Also ich glaube, es gibt natürlich schon starke Unterschiede in der Fragesetzung zwischen der datengetriebenen Forschung und dem datengetriebenen Journalismus.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt enorme Schnittmengen.
Und bevor ich jetzt an die Hertie School gekommen bin, war ich in Zürich an der Uni und da hatten wir auch einen Track im Master, der Datenjournalismus hieß
und der war extrem nachgefragt bei den Studierenden.
Die Studierenden waren dann aber danach auch extrem nachgefragt in Redaktionen.
Und das ist natürlich toll zu sehen, weil das einfach direkt zeigt, dass diese neuen Skills, die Sozialwissenschaftlerinnen sich aneignen, eben auch gefragt sind.
Und ich finde den Trend extrem spannend, weil durch meine Arbeit im Bereich Menschenrechte habe ich schon seit einem knappen Jahrzehnt immer wieder mit Journalisten zu tun,
die sich für unsere Arbeit interessieren und ich sehe einfach eine enorme Veränderung in der Kompetenz, die in Medienhäusern jetzt da ist,
die wirklich verstehen, wovon wir sprechen.
Also als wir vor zehn Jahren über Konflikte gesprochen haben und gesagt haben, passt auf, wir können euch ungefähr sagen, wieviele Menschen hier gestorben sind,
aber es gibt ein Konfidenzintervall, ja, also es gibt eine Unsicherheit, die so und so ist.
Dann kam so, naja also was ist denn ein Konfidenzintervall?
Und heutzutage fragen uns Journalisten, naja aber gibt es da nicht auch eine Unsicherheit?
Also man sieht einfach, dass eine viel größere Kompetenz da ist, was statistische Unsicherheiten angeht.
Und wenn jetzt die ganze Zeit Menschen kommen und sagen, ja wir leben im postfaktischen Zeitalter und niemand interessiert sich mehr für Fakten,
dann verstehe ich das nicht so ganz, weil ich glaube, es gab noch nie so eine große Nachfrage in den Medien für Fakten.
Deshalb, also ich finde das ein bisschen einseitig, wenn man eben davon spricht, dass sich niemand mehr für Fakten interessiert.
Gut Fakten. Die Frage ist, ob man sie zur Kenntnis zu nehmen bereit ist.
Ich glaube, das ist eher das Problem.
Genau.
Aber die, die dafür bereit sind, die wollen dann eben auch Fakten sehen und die sagen, naja, wenn du mir hier jetzt irgendwie sagst, so geht die Wahl aus,
dann möchte ich aber bitte auch sehen, was die Unsicherheit ist.
Ja.
Und das finde ich super.
Man könnte sogar fast sagen, dass diese Fake News-Bewegung, dieses Totschlagargument mit, was kommst du mir mit Fakten?
Das sind ja alles und dann kommen halt diese Verschwörungstheorien so.
Das ist ja alles von langer Hand gesteuert und das kann ja alles gar nicht wahr sein.
Ich glaube, einerseits sieht man das zurecht als das Problem an, dass wir in so einem gesellschaftlichen Diskurs leben,
wo man sich überhaupt mit so was beschäftigen muss.
Man könnte natürlich auch optimistisch rangehen und sagen, naja vielleicht ist das auch schon die letzte Schlacht, die hier geschlagen wird,
weil wie soll man sich sozusagen gegen diesen Faktenwald anders wehren als es generell abzustreiten?
Das fördert natürlich dann wieder die Extreme bis hin zu Leuten, die glauben, die Erde wäre flach oder so, aber das ist halt auch irgendwo am Ende nicht haltbar.
Ja, ich meine, als gute Sozialwissenschaftlerin muss ich jetzt natürlich sagen, ich glaube, wir reden hier von verschiedenen Gruppen.
Ich glaube, es ist auf jeden Fall was dran an dem Argument, zu sagen, es ist jetzt so ein letztes aufbäuschen.
Ich glaube aber auch, dass wir da unterscheiden müssen zwischen verschiedenen Gruppen.
Ich glaube, es gibt im Großteil der Gesellschaft eben einen Push dahin zu sagen, wir sind an Fakten interessiert, wir wollen mehr faktenbasierte Berichterstattung.
Durch die Digitalisierung und durch die sozialen Medienplattformen haben sich natürlich die Randgruppen, die diese Meinung nicht teilen,
jetzt aber natürlich auch zusammengefunden und sich zusammengeschweißt und dadurch eben auch …
Und schreien sich in ihren Echokammern an.
… eine bessere Vernetzung gefunden.
Das heißt, ich weiß gar nicht, vielleicht gibt es Studien dazu, bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, ich weiß gar nicht, ob sich diese Gruppen unbedingt so stark vergrößert haben
oder ob die sich jetzt einfach nur besser vernetzt haben.
Oder sind einfach nur lauter geworden.
Genau.
Ja.
Gibt ja noch eine andere Schnittstelle zwischen Ihrer Arbeit und Journalisten.
Es gibt da unter anderem auch ein Projekt, was sich konkret mit Verfolgung von Journalisten beschäftigt.
Was läuft da ab?
Genau, also als Teil meines Interesses, Menschenrechte qualitativ zu verstehen, habe ich zusammen mit Kollegen versucht,
mal weltweit festzuhalten, in welchen Ländern wo und wie Journalisten eigentlich umgebracht werden.
Und der Grund, warum uns das so stark interessiert, ist zum einen, weil das natürlich an und für sich furchtbare Menschenrechtsverletzungen sind,
zum anderen weil wir aber auch versuchen wollen zu verstehen, wie wir die Verschlechterung von Menschenrechtssituationen besser vorhersagen können.
Also dieses Konzept von Menschenrechtssituationen und Respekt gegenüber individuellen Menschen in Ländern ist so sehr schwammig und irgendwie sehr schwer zu greifen.
Und häufig ist es so, dass, wenn sich die Situation verschlechtert, man das dann immer erst hinterher weiß.
Das ist sozusagen so der Versuch, so einen Index zu bilden.
Der Versuch, irgendwie vorher sagen zu können, naja was ist hier eigentlich los und eventuell könnte es hier bergab gehen, ist gar nicht so einfach.
Weil eben der Respekt von Menschenrechten davon abhängt, inwiefern sich die Polizei verhält, wie sich Sicherheitskräfte verhalten und so weiter und so fort.
Also es gibt quasi verschiedene Dimensionen.
Und eine Sache, die eben immer wieder aufkommt in der Forschung, ist, dass wir wissen, dass Pressefreiheit enorm wichtig ist für eben wieder dieses Thema der Rechenschaft.
Und eben auch ein recht guter Indikator dafür ist, wie es mit der Menschenrechtssituation so steht.
Und aus dem Grund haben wir uns eben dafür interessiert, wo und wann eigentlich Journalisten umgebracht werden.
So ein bisschen als Frühwarnsystem, haben wir so gesagt, um zu verstehen, ob, wenn erst mal Journalisten angegriffen werden, was passiert eigentlich danach?
Ja, was bedeutet das konkret?
Das heißt, es gibt da jetzt eine entsprechende Datenbank, die da gepflegt wird?
Genau, wir haben eine Datenbank gebaut und haben dann in dem ersten Projekt uns angeschaut,
inwiefern die Tötung von Journalisten auf schlimmere Menschenrechtsverletzungen in den kommenden Jahren hinweist.
Und es gibt eben ziemlich robuste statistische Zusammenhänge, die man dort findet.
Das bedeutet ganz konkret, wenn dieses oder letztes Jahr in dem Land, in dem ich lebe, ein Journalist angegriffen wird und getötet wird,
kann ich davon ausgehen, dass allgemein die Menschenrechtssituation im nächsten Jahr nicht mehr so gut aussehen wird in diesem Land.
Einer reicht schon?
Das heißt …
… dass diese Repression sich weiter … genau eine Person reicht schon.
Der Grund, warum eine Person schon reicht, ist, weil natürlich die Tötung die Spitze des Eisberges ist.
Wo Journalisten getötet werden, werden sie auch eingeschüchtert, werden sie eventuell ins Gefängnis gesteckt und so weiter und so fort.
Also wie jetzt der Fall in Malta?
Genau, ich denke, der Fall Malta, der Fall in der Slowakei sind auch so Fälle, die zeigen, dass das alles gar nicht so weit weg passiert,
sondern dass das natürlich auch hier passieren kann.
Und dass es eben Indikatoren dafür sind, dass dort vor Ort was ist, wo man nochmal ein bisschen genauer hinschauen sollte.
Und wieviel Aufwand ist das, so was zu pflegen?
Also macht man das mal so nebenbei oder ist das schon richtig Arbeit?
Der Grund, warum wir uns auf Journalistentötungen fokussiert haben, ist natürlich auch ein recht pragmatischer.
Und das ist, dass Journalisten meistens recht sichtbar sind oder in sehr guten lokalen Netzwerken eingebunden sind.
Das heißt, wenn mal einer umgebracht wird, dann merkt man es auch.
Wenn jemand umgebracht wird, dann wird meistens recht viel Aufmerksamkeit drauf geleitet.
Und deswegen ist das eigentlich was, was man recht gut machen kann und recht gut verfolgen kann.
Aber was kann man da ablesen?
Was kann man wo ablesen?
Na, was kann man jetzt aus diesen gesammelten Daten ableiten?
Naja, ich glaube …
Außer, dass man sie zählen kann.
Ich glaube, man kann ableiten, also zwei Sachen.
Zum einen kann man ableiten, dass, wenn irgendwo Journalisten umgebracht werden, wir ganz genau hinschauen sollten und das eben nicht nur als isolierte Fälle betrachten sollten,
sondern quasi als Spitze des Eisberges und als Vorhut für schlimmere Sachen verstehen sollten.
Und das ist das eine, das andere und das ist das Projekt, an dem wir jetzt gerade arbeiten, ist, dass wir verstehen sollten, in was für Situationen Journalisten eigentlich umgebracht werden.
Also wir haben quasi im ersten Schritt versucht zu gucken, was die Auswirkungen sind.
Und jetzt im zweiten Schritt versuchen wir zu gucken, was die Vorhersagen sind.
Und da sind uns zwei sehr spannende Sachen aufgefallen.
Das erste ist, die meisten Journalisten werden in Demokratien umgebracht.
Und zwar ich rede jetzt nicht von Russland, sondern ich rede von Demokratien.
Ja.
Demokratien, vielleicht sehen wir das vor allem in Demokratien.
Also die gibt es ja auch in verschiedenen Schattierungen so.
Genau, die gibt es in verschiedenen Schattierungen, aber wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass wir von Ländern sprechen, die freie Wahlen haben, bei denen Menschen wählen können und so weiter und so fort.
Bei denen es regelmäßig Veränderungen an der Spitze des Landes gibt, die aufgrund von Wahlen passieren.
Und ich denke, das ist wichtig, weil oft sagen wir, naja das sind dann nicht richtige Demokratien, aber de facto sind das Demokratien, die Menschen dürfen wählen.
Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, warum werden dort Journalisten umgebracht?
Und der zweite spannende Indikator, den wir dann eben sehen, ist, dass Journalisten vor allem in Ländern umgebracht werden,
die ganz starke Dezentralisierung haben, wo viel politische Macht auf der lokalen Ebene platziert ist, also föderalen Systemen.
Und der Grund dafür ist, dass auf lokaler Ebene Journalisten häufig unbequeme Arbeit machen, also zum Beispiel Korruption aufdecken oder irgendwelche anderen Skandälchen aufdecken.
Ich meine, da würde jetzt auch Deutschland dazu gehören.
Da würde Deutschland auch dazu gehören, genau.
Aber Deutschland gehört jetzt nicht zu den Ländern, die da oben in der Liste auftauchen?
Noch nicht, nein.
Okay, noch nicht.
Also Repressionsforscherin bin ich da pessimistisch und sage mal, noch nicht.
Okay. Was taucht denn oben auf?
Mexiko taucht oben auf, Brasilien taucht oben auf, die Philippinen tauchen oben auf, das sind, glaube ich, so die Top 3 Länder in unserer Datenbank.
Aber viele andere Länder auch.
Also Malta taucht darin jetzt natürlich auch auf.
Also was wir eben sehen, ist, wenn es starke Dezentralisierung gibt, wo viel politische Macht auf der subnationalen Ebene ist
und es gleichzeitig demokratisch ist und Journalisten denken, wir sind hier eigentlich geschützt in einem Rechtsstaat, in dem wir unsere Arbeit machen können,
es aber nicht die rechtlichen Strukturen gibt, um diese Journalisten auch zu schützen, das sind genau die Situationen, in denen Journalisten dann umgebrachte werden.
Weil die berichten dann nämlich über irgendwelche Skandale und die werden dann entsorgt.
Das beutetet, wenn wir dafür uns quasi einsetzen, dass wir sagen, es muss Dezentralisierung geben, es muss mehr Macht irgendwie auf lokale Strukturen übertragen werden
und dann investieren wir aber nicht gleichzeitig in die Rechtsstaatlichkeit, das sind dann die Situationen, in denen wir im Grunde genommen die Situation von Journalisten auf der lokalen Ebene extrem gefährlich machen.
Jetzt haben wir viel gesprochen über das Digitale als Werkzeug.
Konkretes Forschungsobjekt, aber vor allem so als Methode, wie man der Gesellschaft ein wenig auf die Schliche kommen kann.
Jetzt leben wir ja aber, wie man so schön sagt, in Zeiten der Digitalisierung, sprich, wir haben uns Kommunikationsmitte zugelegt mit dem Internet und all dem, was darauf aufbaut,
was den Informationsfluss, den Informationsreichtum und natürlich dann vor allem eben auch die Kommunikation enorm beschleunigt
und die Auswirkungen davon dürfte, glaube ich, jeder schon mal auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise gespürt haben.
Und man hat jetzt eben auch so diese Eindruck, dass das eben auch so das Wohl und Wehe gesamter Staaten doch enorm in Bedrängung bringt
Mir ist es das erste Mal so ein bisschen aufgefallen zu Zeiten des arabischen Frühlings vor einigen Jahren.
Das war ja dann sozusagen auch die Story erst mal, oh ja alle vernetzen sich jetzt über Facebook und die ganzen Aktivisten kommen zusammen
und das Volk hat auf einmal einen gemeinsamen Sprachkanal gefunden und steht auf gegen die Machthaber
und das hat ja in Tunesien dann ein Stück weit auch ganz gut funktioniert, gab wieder ein paar Schritte zurück und auch wieder ein paar nach vorne
und im Großen und Ganzen ist in Tunesien jetzt nicht ganz so explodiert, aber wir haben ja dann gesehen, es wurde in Ägypten, dann lief es dann schon so ein bisschen anders,
war dann zwar genauso umjubelt, aber dort ist dann der Staat ja auch schnell vorgegangen dagegen und hat versucht,
in irgendeiner Form die Verbreitung dieser Informationen zu beeinflussen.
Da wurde dann tagelang das Internet abgeschaltet und noch extremer wurde es ja dann ein paar Monate später, als die Proteste in Syrien entflammt sind
und da wissen wir ja nun alle, was da rausgekommen ist, also schön war das nicht.
Sprich, so dieser ganze Traum von der Befreiung von der geknechteten Völker, weil man jetzt Textmessages durchs Internet verschicken kann, der war dann relativ schnell ausgeträumt.
Was sind denn das jetzt so für Implikationen, auf die man blicken muss und inwiefern betrifft das auch Ihre Forschung?
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist eine sehr gute Zusammenfassung von der Perspektive, die wir vor allem in Europa und den USA, glaube ich, von dieser Entwicklung hatten,
und ich glaube, diese Linse, durch die man hier so ein bisschen dieses Aufbauschen, Aufbäumen der verschiedenen Protestbewegungen im Kontext des sogenannten arabischen Frühlings hat,
hat natürlich auch sehr gut in diese Narrative gepasst, dass die sozialen Medien und diese verschiedenen Plattformen, die ja vor allem eigentlich aus den USA und Europa kommen,
so ein bisschen diese Liberalisierung vorantreiben.
Und ich glaube, jetzt knapp zehn Jahre später hat man so ein bisschen einen anderen Blick darauf.
Man sagt, natürlich war das irgendwie auch wichtig auch für die Kommunikation, aber es waren jetzt natürlich nicht die originären Auslöser dieser Protestbewegungen.
Die haben uns natürlich dabei geholfen, das Ganze hier mitzuverfolgen und Menschen konnten sich ganz gut miteinander vernetzen,
aber es war jetzt nicht originär der Hauptgrund dafür.
Das beutetet natürlich aber nicht, dass die Rolle des Internets in der Digitalisierung gleich null war, also im Gegenteil.
Ich glaube, wir haben ganz klar gesehen, dass das Internet ganz viele verschiedene Rollen im Kontext dieser Konflikte und Proteste gespielt hat.
Was mich von Anfang an sehr stark interessiert hat, ist, und das kommt natürlich von meiner Forschungslinse, dass ich mich eben originär für staatlichen Machtmissbrauch
und staatliche Kontrolle interessiere, war eben, dass eben ganz früh in dieser Diskussion um sogenannte Liberalisierungstechnologien so ein bisschen vernachlässigt wurde,
dass das Internet ja immer noch als Infrastruktur meistens von Staaten bereitgestellt wird oder zumindest wurde, auch wenn sich das jetzt langsam verändert.
Das beutetet, für mich war eigentlich von Anfang an sehr spannend zu sehen, naja wenn das wirklich so toll ist für die ganzen nichtstaatlichen Bewegungen und Protestbewegungen,
warum wird es dann überhaupt zugelassen?
Und ich meine, Ägypten hat versucht, es auszuschalten, hat dann gemerkt, dass das eigentlich keine so gute Idee ist, dass das eher noch Leute befeuert hat, auf die Straße zu gehen.
Bzw. ja auch dann zu dem Zeitpunkt schon enormen Schaden auch für die Wirtschaft wiederum bedeutet hat.
Genau, die Wirtschaft ist natürlich ein anderer Bereich, wo es auch wichtig ist.
Tourismus insbesondere.
Aber originär ist natürlich schon die Frage, warum machen die das dann?
Warum wird dieses Internet überhaupt zugelassen, wenn es wirklich Revolutionen hervorruft?
Und ich glaube, jetzt ist die Situation ein bisschen eine andere, weil man jetzt natürlich auch im Kontext von den US-Wahlen 2016, im Kontext von Brexit sich viel mehr Gedanken darüber macht,
inwiefern das Internet vielleicht negative Konsequenzen hätte, vor allem auch in Demokratien.
Aber damals wurde das eigentlich so ein bisschen unter den Tisch fallen gelassen.
Dabei gab es auch schon 2012/2013 extrem, also schon früher, 2008 extrem gute Forschung, die gezeigt hat,
wie Staaten überall auf der Welt das Internet zensieren, das Internet überwachen, das Internet manipulieren, und zwar zu ihrem eigenen Vorteil.
Und ich glaube, das hat man im Zuge dieser Euphorie so ein bisschen vergessen.
Und im Kontext der Enthüllungen durch Edward Snowden wurde dann das Ausmaß oder die Möglichkeiten, die überhaupt durch Überwachung möglich sind,
so ein bisschen weltweit publiker.
Es hat natürlich auch den Effekt gehabt, dass dann viele Staaten, die eben nicht diese Kapazitäten hatten, die die US-Regierung hat,
gesagt haben, naja das möchten wir jetzt aber auch haben.
Und ich glaube, seitdem sehen wir eben jetzt nur noch viel viel stärkere, ein viel viel stärkeres Interesse seitens demokratischer, nichtdemokratischer, despotischer Machthaber,
die sagen, also wenn die NSA das kann, dann wollen wir das auch können.
Ich meine, es gab ja schon immer so ein paar digitale Warner, die im Prinzip schon seit den 80/90er Jahren generell immer so mit diesem Feindbild des übermächtigen Staates daher gekommen sind.
Digitale Szene in Deutschland ist im Prinzip seit den 80er Jahren schon ganz stark davon geprägt, sozusagen auch ein bisschen so als digitale Fortsetzung dieser Friedensbewegung,
mit dieser generellen Staatsskepsis.
Ich erinnere mich noch an die Proteste gegen die Volkszählung, die heutzutage also jedes Webseitenformular, was Mindestdaten von einem haben will, hat dann schon mehr Informationen eingesammelt als damals die Volkszählung wollte,
aber man merkte zumindest, dass dieser Diskurs dadurch schon angefangen hat und dass es dann halt auch immer so der Staat war.
Jetzt wiederum haben wir natürlich auch eine Situation, wo man eben sieht, naja es ist auch gar nicht mal jetzt nur der Staat, sondern wir haben im Prinzip das Problem,
dass durch die privaten Dienste, die halt noch viel extremer zentralisiert genutzt werden, Facebook natürlich, aber eben auch andere Dienste und was immer auch da nach Facebook kommen wird,
wird das Problem natürlich dann auch haben.
Das verschwindet jetzt nicht dadurch, dass ein einzelner Anbieter dann vielleicht irgendwann mal in den Niedergang schreitet
Dass wir dann im Prinzip zwei große Konfliktfelder haben.
Aber bleiben wir vielleicht erst mal so ein bisschen bei den Staaten und ich würde auch ganz gerne nochmal gucken, wie das jetzt zum Beispiel konkret beim arabischen Frühling …
Also ich weiß nicht, der Begriff trifft es irgendwie nicht richtig, aber sagen wir mal, insbesondere den Syrienkonflikt angegangen hat,
weil Syrien ja, glaube ich, sehr viel mehr als andere Staaten davor von Vornherein einfach auf maximale Konfrontation gegangen ist.
Was kann man aus den Vorgängen, also Sie haben sich ja, glaube ich, Syrien ein bisschen genauer angeschaut, was da abgegangen ist, was ist da passiert
und aus welcher Motivation heraus, welchen Möglichkeiten heraus hat der Staat dort agiert?
Ja, also ich denke, der syrische Konflikt ist für zukünftige Konflikte eigentlich, also aus verschiedenen Gründen, extrem wichtig.
Und ich glaube, gerade im Bezug auf die Rolle von der Digitalisierung, vom Internet allgemein, ist eigentlich der syrische Konflikt wirklich der erste,
wo wir so eine zentrale Rolle eigentlich sehen.
Die syrische Regierung hatte bis kurz vor Anfang der Proteste, also bis, ich glaube, Januar oder Februar 2011, eine extrem starke digitale Zensur durchgeführt.
Also es war wirklich einer der am stärksten zensiertesten Medienlandschaften der ganzen Region vor Ort dort.
Und dann kurz bevor eben diese Proteste ausgebrochen sind, hat man eben plötzlich dann irgendwie diese ganzen Seiten, die vorher blockiert waren,
hat man dann eben entblockiert und die Leute hatten plötzlich Zugriff dadruaf.
Jetzt weiß man natürlich nicht, was der genaue Grund dafür war.
Aber viele regionale Spezialisten und die eben sich auch sehr gut mit der Geschichte der syrischen Regierung und der ganzen Region auskennen,
sagen eben, naja ein zentrales Problem, was Diktatoren haben, das weiß man, ist, dass sie so ein bisschen in einem Dilemma stecken.
Auf der einen Seite wollen sie soweit es geht kritische Stimmen zensieren und die quasi mundtot machen.
Das kann aber die Folge haben, dass in Situationen, wo sich in der Gesellschaft Unmut anbahnt und es quasi brodelt, man das nicht wirklich mitbekommt.
Weil man quasi die Menschen so stark zensiert hat, dass man dann vom einen Moment auf den anderen überrascht wird, was da eigentlich passiert.
Und deswegen haben eben repressive Herrscher immer so diese Trade off, dass sie auf der einen Seite sagen, wir wollen die Leute unterdrücken,
aber wir wollen trotzdem noch wissen, wer nachher die Anführer wären, sollten sie sich gegen uns aufbäuschen.
Und dieses Entblockieren von sozialen Medienplattformen ist natürlich eine extrem, kann man sagen, elegante Art herauszufinden,
wer eigentlich diese zentralen Figuren sind.
Das ist jetzt natürlich sehr weit gegriffen, aber es gibt schon relativ viele Stimmen, die eben gesagt haben, naja das war ein Weg für die syrische Regierung herauszufinden,
wer jetzt eigentlich die wirklich problematischen Stimmen innerhalb der Bevölkerung sind.
Und vor allem, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, zu dem Zeitpunkt war auch, glaube ich, der Zugang zu Facebook noch nicht mal verschlüsselt.
Genau, der Zugang zu Facebook war nicht verschlüsselt und allgemein …
Das ist unglaublich.
… muss man sich ja auch vorstellen, sogar innerhalb von vielen Ländern, wo das Internet schon lange frei zugänglich sind, haben die meisten Menschen trotzdem noch furchtbare Sicherheitspraxen,
also benutzen das gleiche Passwort oder schützen es nicht oder sonst irgendwas.
Und man kann sich natürlich vorstellen, dass in einem Land, wo diese ganzen Seiten nicht verfügbar waren, man vielleicht erst mal so euphorisch war,
dass man die jetzt benutzen kann, als dass man jetzt sofort irgendwie an Informationssicherheit denkt.
Klar.
Das heißt, man hat im Grunde genommen da extrem von profitieren wollen von Seiten der Regierung.
Und hat wahrscheinlich auch davon profitiert.
Man hat davon profitiert, man hat aber wahrscheinlich auch unterschätzt, wie stark die Proteste ausfallen würden
und dass extreme Repressionen, wie sie in den 80er Jahren zum Beispiel schon funktioniert hat im Kontext von Syrien, dann die Leute nicht mehr davon abhalten würde zu protestieren.
Und was mich eben in meiner Forschung interessiert hat war, naja der syrische Konflikt ist eine Situation, in der das Internet so wichtig ist,
inwiefern wird es denn wirklich konkret von der Regierung als Teil ihrer repressiven Strategie benutzt?
Und mit repressive Strategie meine ich also physische Gewalt.
Inwiefern ist es wirklich Teil der militärischen Kampagne?
Und da habe ich mich eben vor allem dafür interessiert, wann wird der Zugang zum Internet abgebrochen für die lokale Bevölkerung?
Und wann lässt man die Bevölkerung eigentlich das Internet benutzen?
Und?
Und die Ergebnisse zeigen eben ziemlich stark, dass das Internet eigentlich dann meistens unterbrochen wird, wenn man eh vor Ort quasi willkürliche Gewalt anwendet.
Wenn man reingeht, extreme Bombardierungen vornimmt, willkürlich Menschen unterdrückt und so weiter und so fort.
Und dass dort, wo man das Internet anlässt, die Leute das benutzen können, man dann natürlich die Informationen darüber, wer wo ist, wer vielleicht einem nicht so wohlgesinnt ist,
dass man die dann dafür nutzt, gezielte Gewalt anzuwenden.
Das heißt, in einem „Normalbetrieb“ ist es sehr viel „nützlicher“ zu beobachten und mal alle schön ihre sozialen Netzwerke verflechten zu lassen,
um diese dann als solche bewerten zu können, weil man sieht ja dann, wer mit wem und Gruppen und überhaupt und Aktivitäten
und das lässt sich ja dann quasi alles aus den Daten mehr oder weniger mühelos herausfühlen.
Aber in dem Moment, wo das Netz dann ein Warnsystem ist, ein Alarmsignal sein kann, in dem Moment wird es einfach knallhart ausgeschaltet?
Genau. Und man muss sich natürlich auch überlegen, in welchen Regionen eigentlich diese Informationen, die man über das Internet bekommen kann, wichtig sind.
Und was ich dann eben finde ist, dass dieses Ausspionieren, sagen wir mal, durch das verfügbare Internet vor allem in Regionen wichtig ist,
in denen man vielleicht sonst keine anderen Strukturen hat.
Also Überwachung wurde natürlich schon lange vor dem Internet als Strategie angewendet.
Und Überwachung ist natürlich besonders einfach in Regionen, wo man viele Menschen hat, die loyal gegenüber dem Regime sind,
wo man vielleicht viele Truppen vor Ort hat, da braucht man das Internet nicht unbedingt.
Das Internet braucht man in den Regionen, wo man sonst nicht besonders guten Zugang hat.
Und das ist eben eine Implikation, die ich extrem wichtig finde für zukünftige Konflikte.
Wir wissen, dass territoriale Kontrolle, wie wir es nennen, also quasi wer vor Ort das Sagen hat in Konfliktsituationen viel darüber aussagt, was für eine Gewalt angewendet wird
oder wieviel Gewalt angewendet wird, das ist was, was wir schon lange aus der Konfliktforschung wissen.
Beispiel?
Also ein Beispiel dafür ist, wenn ich eine Stadt eingenommen habe als Regierung, also wenn die syrische Regierung eine Stadt unter ihrer Kontrolle hat,
dann kann sie natürlich vor Ort viel besser rumgehen, in den Nachbarschaften gucken, wer eigentlich quasi vielleicht ein Problem darstellt oder nicht.
Wenn ich wenig Informationen habe, wenn ich wenig Kontrolle habe, werde ich vielleicht extremere Gewalt anwenden.
Und das Internet kann jetzt aber der Regierung in Regionen, in denen sie sonst keinen Zugang hätte, also zum Beispiel weil das Regionen sind,
in denen die Rebellen sich verstecken oder in denen die Bevölkerung sagt, wir kooperieren nicht mit euch, das verschafft denen da jetzt eben einen neuen Vorteil.
Und ich glaube, das hat eine Implikation dafür, wie Konflikte zukünftig ausgetragen werden.
Das heißt, alles wird jetzt schlimmer durch Internet?
Nein, das will ich nicht unbedingt sagen, es verändert sich.
Okay.
Also ich meine, wenn man ganz ganz ganz zynisch wäre, und man sagen würde, naja bei gezielter Gewalt werden weniger Menschen umgebracht,
könnte man ja sagen, na ist doch super.
Jetzt gibt es vielleicht weniger Kollateralschaden.
Ja.
Das sieht natürlich anders aus aus der Perspektive von denen, die dadurch gezielt angegriffen werden.
Was ist denn jetzt so der Trend?
Also ich meine, man muss ja nur einmal so ein bisschen durch das Internet blättern und man sieht, dass mittlerweile eigentlich nichts mehr heilig ist.
Also es wird in jeden Kommunikationskanal eingegriffen, der sich in irgendeiner Form auch nur anbietet.
Wir hatten ja schon erwähnt die Veröffentlichung von Edward Snowden, da haben wir ja sehr viel gezeigt, man kann das gar nicht alles aufzählen,
aber unter anderem so Dinge, die bis wenige Monate vorher noch so in den Bereich der Verschwörungstheorie fallen von irgendwelchen Aktivisten.
So was wie, ja ich kaufe mir bei Amazon einen Ethernet Router und wenn der bei mir ankommt, dann hat die CIA da schon was eingepflanzt.
Also wenn man so was irgendwie gesagt hat, selbst in etwas informierteren Kreise, wurde man schon so ein bisschen mitleidig angeschaut und so,
dann nimm doch einfach deine Medizin wieder und dann wird das schon irgendwie hinhauen und dann kriegte man im Prinzip genau das auf den Tisch,
ja genau, findet genauso statt und fertig.
So dass man jetzt so ein bisschen, glaube ich, auch dahingeht, allen alles zuzutrauen.
Und wenn man aber sich dann die weitere Entwicklung anschaut, hört es auch irgendwie nicht auf.
Also gerade, ich glaube, in den arabischen Ländern ist sehr beliebter Sport halt auch diese ganzen Möglichkeiten der gezielten Infiltration von Geräten zu nutzen,
das heißt, das was wir hier noch so ein bisschen in einer Sicherheitsdebatte hin und her schieben und sagen, naja sollten wir nicht dafür sorgen,
dass irgendwie unsere Systeme sicher sind oder zumindest die Politik sagt, dass es ja ganz toll und eigentlich auch ihr Auftrag wäre,
aber wir müssen ja die bösen Terroristen fangen und deswegen müssen wir uns auch die Möglichkeit lassen, dann doch mal irgendwo einzudringen,
womit natürlich dann diese Sicherheit untergraben wird, das ist ja dann so was in den vereinigten arabischen Emiraten etc. ist das ja sozusagen staatliche Politik,
wo dann eben auch die privaten Betreiber so sehr unter der Fuchtel stehen, dass sie dann zu solchen technischen Maßnahmen, die das unterstützen, auch gezwungen werden.
Wie entwickelt sich das denn weltweit so aus Ihrer Perspektive?
Huh, große Frage.
Naja.
Also ich glaube,…
Sie haben die Daten.
Naja zum einen muss man sagen, die empirische Überwachungsforschung, also mit empirisch meine ich jetzt die Überwachungsforschung, die versucht, das Ganze anhand von Daten festzuhalten,
hat natürlich enorme Probleme, ganz einfach aus dem Grund, dass wir natürlich über Überwachungstechnologie erfahren, wenn diejenigen, die sie eingebaut haben,
vielleicht wollen, dass man was darüber erfährt oder wenn es eben Pannen gibt.
Das bedeutet, dass natürlich die Informationen, die wir darüber haben, immer lückenhaft sein wird und lückenhaft ist.
Und das ist ein riesiges Problem für die Art von Arbeit, die wir machen, die Art von Arbeit, die Aktivisten machen und das ist was, wo ich auch keine Lösung weiß.
Was, glaube ich, deutlich wird in der jetzigen Debatte, ist, dass wir, ich glaube, langsam davon wegkommen, die Akteure, die in diesem Bereich agieren, versuchen,
sagen wir mal, relativ binär zu kategorisieren.
Also ich glaube, es gab relativ lang und das gilt wahrscheinlich vor allem für die Zeit vor den Enthüllungen durch Edward Snowden, dass man so ein bisschen gesagt hat,
naja es gibt irgendwie diese autokratischen Regierungen, die machen was, das ist schlimm und dann gibt es diese demokratischen Regierungen und die machen das anders.
Und ich glaube, was wir jetzt einfach sehen, ist, das diese Software überall benutzt wird.
Die Frage ist natürlich, wofür sie benutzt wird und wie sie eingesetzt wird, da kann man natürlich schon nochmal unterscheiden zwischen Ländern,
die vielleicht sich eher an rechtsstaatliche Gesetze halten als an andere.
Aber die Software, die verkauft und genutzt wird, die verteilt sich weltweit relativ gut.
Das heißt, da jetzt zu unterscheiden, das kann man vielleicht auf politischer Ebene, aber sonst wird es da schwierig.
Also wir sehen, dass viele der Programme, die von der syrischen Regierung eingesetzt werden, von Firmen aus Deutschland kamen, von Firmen aus Kalifornien kamen.
Dass viel aber auch heimisch selbst geschrieben wurde und deswegen ist das alles in dem Sinne schon versetzt.
Dass viele dieser Firmen, die sich jetzt gerade in dem Bereich spezialeren, aus Israel kommen, eng zusammenarbeiten mit amerikanischen Firmen.
Also ich glaube, da jetzt irgendwie unterscheiden zu wollen, das ist was, was wir eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich machen können.
Naja, mittlerweile haben wir da ja auch einen neuen Begriff, der Cyberwar, der definitiv insofern stattfindet, als dass ja im Prinzip ja auch schon größere Truppen abgestellt werden.
In diesem Fall werden die Leute halt nicht an richtigen Waffen ausgebildet, sondern es wird halt einfach ihre technische Expertise genutzt bzw. auch durch eigene Ausbildung vorangetrieben.
Gibt es da irgendwie schon so ein Bild, wer da ganz vorne mitmarschiert und diese Idee einer elektronischen Kriegsführung auch klar formuliert?
Also als Wissenschaftlerin finde ich den Begriff Cyberwar immer ein bisschen schwierig, weil die Frage ist so ein bisschen, also das ist so ein bisschen die Frage,
Was ist Cyberwar?
Ist der Cyberwar so was wie der War On Terror oder War On Drugs?
Also heutzutage ist alles Krieg auf einmal.
Ja.
Und das passt insofern, als dass jetzt viele Leute von hybrider Kriegsführung sprechen.
Also bei der hybriden Kriegsführung gehen wir ja auch davon aus, dass alle Gesellschaftsbereiche irgendwie offen sind für kriegerische Handlungen.
Deswegen das finde ich ein bisschen schwierig, diesen Begriff Cyberkrieg wirklich zu benutzen in diesem Kontext.
Was ganz klar ist, ist, dass die Cyberdimension Teil der modernen Kriegsführung ist.
Ich glaube, den können wir aber nicht unabhängig von der ganz konventionellen kinetischen Kriegsführung sehen, sondern eher als integrativer Teil davon.
Das heißt, wenn sich jetzt zwei Staaten oder ein Staat und ein nichtstaatlicher Akteur gegenüber stehen und kriegerische Handlungen ausführen,
dann wird sich das auf den digitalen Raum ausweiten.
Ich meine, ich rede ja jetzt vielleicht … ich wollte jetzt nicht den Eindruck machen, dass es jetzt so mit Zerstörung zu tun hat.
Ich meine, auch das haben wir gehabt, also Stuxnet und ähnliche Fälle, wo halt konkret Malware handgeschneidert wurde, um eben Maschinen zu zerstören.
Das war eine interessante Machtdemonstration, aber sicherlich nichts, was sich jetzt beliebig skalieren lässt.
Aber was wir ja gesehen haben, was extrem gut skaliert, ist einfach die Beeinflussung der öffentlichen Meinung über entsprechende digitale Strategien,
wo ja dann schon eine Heerschar von Leuten daran beteiligt ist, kann man dann vielleicht schon auch von einer Armee und von einem Krieg sprechen.
Der halt ein Informationskrieg ist.
Was aber nichts neues ist, weil jeder konventionelle Krieg auch immer mit Flugblättern und Falschmeldungen etc. gearbeitet hat
und wir wissen, also gerade im Krieg stirbt die Wahrheit als erstes und das ist natürlich dann hier nicht anders oder?
Ja. Also ich glaube, kurz um nochmal auf den Stuxnet-Fall einzugehen, ich glaube, der zeigt ganz deutlich und da sind sich die meisten Experten einig,
man redet zwar immer davon, dass Cyberkrieg ist so was günstiges und Cyberkapazitäten sind günstig,
aber de facto sehen wir eigentlich, dass die Militärs, die jetzt ganz vorne dabei sind, was Cyberkapazitäten angeht, trotzdem die sind, die auch im nicht digitalen Raum auch eigentlich ganz vorne mit dabei sind.
Das heißt, im Moment gibt es auf jeden Fall noch eine ganz starke Korrelation zwischen Militärsgröße und Technologieaffinität innerhalb der Militärs.
Also die USA natürlich ist ganz vorne dabei.
Stuxnet war ein amerikanisch-israelisches Kollaborationsprojekt, diese beiden Militärs sind natürlich auch in anderen Bereichen ganz vorne weit dabei.
Die Bundesregierung hat jetzt auch stark in den Bereich investiert, man hat vielleicht ein bisschen länger gebraucht,
aber man ist jetzt trotzdem, man hat da sehr stark aufgerüstet in dem Bereich, da passt das Wort jetzt vielleicht ganz gut.
Deswegen, also die Gefahr zum Beispiel davor …
also eine Sache, die natürlich immer genannt wird im Bereich Cyberkrieg, ist, dass das jetzt eine Möglichkeit ist für nicht staatliche Akteure, ganz stark Einfluss zu nehmen.
De facto haben wir bislang relativ wenig Evidenzen für sogenannte Cyberterror-Vorfälle gesehen.
Was vielleicht auch darauf hindeutet, dass die Kapazitäten im Bereich Cyber doch sehr stark mit anderen militärischen Kapazitäten zusammenhängen.
Ich glaube, davon unabhängig, also von diesen wirklichen, sagen wir mal, militärischen Cyberkapazitäten, ist natürlich die Frage,
inwiefern das Internet durch nicht kriegerische Handlungen für Propaganda und Manipulation benutzt wird.
Und ich glaube, das ist nochmal, ich würde das ein bisschen wahrscheinlich unterscheiden zwischen diesen, sagen wir mal, eher traditionellen Cyberkapazitäten.
Ja gut, ich meine, Krieg heißt ja auch nur, dass man mit Gewalt seine Meinung durchsetzen will sozusagen oder seine Vormachtstellung oder seine Einflusssphäre erweitern möchte.
Und früher war das halt im Wesentlichen eine geografische Frage, heute ist es das teilweise auch noch,
aber um jetzt sozusagen den Machtdiskurs, den globalen, zu gewinnen, hat es eben auch sehr viel mehr mit dem zu tun, was die Leute denn halt eigentlich so denken
und wie dann eben ihre eigenen Entscheidungen ausfallen.
Ich meine, bisher ist jetzt noch nichts nachhaltig bewiesen, aber, ich glaube, jeder, wer sich das im Detail so ein bisschen angeschaut hat,
wie so die Wahlen in den USA 2016 abgelaufen sind, weiß, da ist nicht alles mit richtigen Dingen zugegangen
und insbesondere war halt die Einflussnahme über so Unternehmen wie Cambridge Analytica, die ja im Prinzip auch nichts anderes gemacht haben als Sie jetzt,
also so BigData Analyse und wir schauen uns das mal ganz genau an und wir haben da irgendwie Zugriff bekommen auf viele Facebook-Accounts
und jetzt wissen wir genau, wer hier wie denkt und dann schicken wir den Leuten entsprechende Botschaften,
die zwar nicht stimmen, aber sie halt in irgendeiner Form in die Richtung bringen, wo wir sie hin haben möchten.
Also Unterstützer der Demokraten werden davon abgehalten zur Wahl zu gehen und die Republikaner werden halt noch weiter aufgehetzt als sie es ohnehin schon sind
und das Ergebnis haben wir dann gesehen.
Ähnlich die Wahl oder die Abstimmung über den Austritt von Großbritannien, von dem keiner weiß, ob er denn jetzt überhaupt nochmal stattfinden wird,
aber immerhin ist er noch geplant.
Auch da ist ja diese Einflussnahme enorm.
Und wenn man sich jetzt mal den Aufwand anschaut, den das gekostet hat, im Vergleich zu der Wirkung, also aus russischer Perspektive auf jeden Fall genau das,
was sozusagen im eigenen Interesse ist, nämlich eine Destabilisierung anderer staatlicher Strukturen,
die dann natürlich entsprechend schwächer dastehen,
kann man doch schon von Krieg sprechen.
Ja, also ich meine, der Begriff Krieg, glaube ich, ist weit ausdehnbar oder eng ausdehnbar, je nachdem wie man das sieht.
Aber ich glaube, der Punkt, den Sie gerade angesprochen haben, ist wichtig, dass wir bei diesen Kampagnen, sage ich mal in Anführungszeichen, oder ein bisschen neutraler als Krieg,
bei diesen Kampagnen, die gestartet werden, glaube ich, stark zu unterscheiden ist zwischen dem intendierten Effekt, dem tatsächlichen Effekt und der eigentlichen Einflussnahme.
Weil, ich glaube, der Punkt, den Sie gerade angesprochen haben, meine jetzige Einschätzung der Situation basierend auf der Forschung meiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und der Forschung, die ich selber mache, ist, dass eben die Einflussnahme, die wir gesehen haben oder die wir auch zum Beispiel sehen in Deutschland im Kontext der jetzigen europäischen Wahlen,
im Kontext von Brexit, im Kontext von den US-Wahlen war nicht, gewisse Parteien zu pushen oder Kandidaten oder Kandidatinnen zu pushen,
sondern es ging tatsächlich um Destabilisierung, es ging um Vertrauensverlust in Institutionen.
Die Zerrüttung des Diskurses, könnte man sagen.
Genau. Das sind eigentlich so die Sachen, die wir eher sehen.
Also eine Schwächung der Gesellschaft als solcher.
Genau. Eine Schwächung des gesellschaftlichen Vertrauens in Institutionen, in demokratische Institutionen.
Genau.
Und ich glaube, das ist eine andere Art von Kampagne als gezielte Einflussnahme, um einen gewissen Kanditen oder eine gewissen Kandidatin zu bekommen.
Und ich glaube, dieses Framing weg von, die Wahl wurde beeinflusst, um eine Person zu wählen, zu, die Wahl wurde als Anlass genommen,
demokratische Institutionen zu destabilisieren, sollte hoffentlich mehr gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt bekommen, dieses Problem anzusprechen.
Also doch mehr so ein Zauberlehrlingseffekt, so die Geister, die ich rief?
Also ich glaube schon, dass …
Gott, jetzt haben sie ihn wirklich gewählt.
… dass wir das eigentlich so framen müssen.
Und ich glaube, was mich so ein bisschen an dieser Diskussion stört um die US-Wahlen, ist, dass wir dieses Diskussion so nicht haben würden, wenn Hillary Clinton gewonnen hätte,
egal ob die Einflussnahme gewesen wäre oder nicht.
Das heißt, dieser Diskurs, das Ganze wurde fremd gelenkt, passt natürlich sehr gut zu den Trump-Kritikern, die sagen, naja er wäre gar nicht sonst gewählt worden.
Die Spezialisten im Bereich Wahlforschung sind sich dessen gar nicht so sicher.
Also es ist nicht wirklich klar, ob dieser Einfluss so einen großen Effekt hatte oder nicht, aber es passt sehr gut in dieses Narrativ, das wir eben haben, dass das alles fremdgelenkt wurde.
Das gleiche mit Brexit.
Natürlich gab es große Desinformationskampagnen innerhalb von Brexit, aber dafür hat man vielleicht gar nicht Russland gebraucht,
das haben gewisse Parteien innerhalb von der Wahl selber gemacht, indem sie eben falsche Informationen verbreitet haben.
Na gut, aber es ist ja unter anderem im Falle von Brexit nachgewiesen, dass halt diese Twitter-Armeen, die da sozusagen diese Scheinuser schon Jahre vorher in diesem Bereich gewildert haben.
Und damit in gewisser Hinsicht halt schon so auch die Saat ausgelegt haben, aus dem das dann eben so hat eskalieren können.
Genau, aber das wäre sicher nicht passiert, wenn es nicht auch sehr kollaborationsfreudige lokale Akteure davon gegeben hätte.
Ja klar, die haben es natürlich aufgegriffen und die werden dann halt eben unterfüttert.
Also letzten Endes und das vielleicht jetzt nochmal eine Interessante Perspektive, die ich mich auch selber eben sozusagen frage
und ich weiß nicht, ob die Forschung da irgendwelche Antworten zu liefern in der Lage ist,
ist denn die Gesellschaft ausreichend lernfähig, um mit diesem Wandel dieser digitalen Rahmenbedingungen langfristig auch klarzukommen?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, wir sehen nicht, dass allgemein Vertrauen in Medien sich stark verändert.
Also vielleicht am Rande von gewissen gesellschaftlichen Gruppen, aber wir stehen ganz am Anfang von diesem Digitalisierungsprojekt.
Medien jetzt im Sinne von journalistische Medien oder?
Journalistische Medien, genau.
Okay, gut, aber ich meine, das ist ja auch der Diskurs untereinander, der sozusagen hier Gefahr läuft, aus dem Ruder zu laufen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, man darf zum einen nicht überschätzen, was dort für Effekte quasi losgetreten wurden durch diese neuen Medien.
Man darf aber auch nicht unterschätzen, wie stark sie auch dazu geführt haben, dass Leute jetzt mit Menschen diskutieren, mit denen sie vorher nicht diskutiert hätten.
Das heißt, diese Idee, dass Menschen, die soziale Medien benutzen, um zum Beispiel ihre Informationen zu bekommen, weniger "variety"…
Varietät.
Variation, das war das Wort.
Variation.
Das Menschen, die soziale Medien benutzen, um an ihre Nachrichten zu kommen, jetzt weniger Variation haben.
Das hat sich auch alles so ein bisschen als nicht unbedingt richtig entpuppt.
Also wenn ich nur Zeitungen lese und immer meine eine Zeitung lese, die immer die gleiche Meinung vertritt, habe ich eventuell genauso einen engen Blickwinkel, wie wenn ich meine Nachrichten online bekomme
Ja klar, also ich meine, die Bildzeitung gibt es ja auch schon ein bisschen länger, das ist jetzt in dem Sinne kein neues Phänomen.
Aber es ist ja sozusagen, ich habe so das Gefühl, die Gesellschaft muss sich überhaupt erst mal daran gewöhnen, dass man jetzt auch über lokale und natürlich auch Klassengrenzen,
mal grob formuliert, hinaus, also so dieser globale Stammtischdiskurs, der vorher halt dann immer doch sehr lokal gekapselt war,
weil er eben sozusagen kein Medium als Transport hatte, hat eben jetzt genau dieses und es bewirkt dann zu dieser Verstärkung des Wahnsinns.
Genau, aber ich finde es ganz spannend, was Sie jetzt gesagt haben, weil im Grunde genommen, womit wir ja lernen müssen umzugehen ist nicht mit unserer sogenannten Bubble,
sondern wir müssen lernen damit umzugehen, dass wir jetzt eine viel größere Heterogenität an Meinungen auf uns zuprallen haben.
Und die scheint im Moment viele Menschen einfach noch enorm zu verunsichern und einfach wütend zu machen.
Aber das ist ein anderes Problem als, wir sitzen alle in unseren Kammern und reden nicht mit Menschen, die nicht unserer Meinung sind.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, dahingehend muss noch ganz viel passieren.
Wie gehe ich damit um, wenn ich jetzt auf einmal merke, dass mein Nachbar rassistischere Tendenzen hatte, als ich gemerkt habe in unserem normalen Zusammenleben?
Wie gehe ich damit um, dass ich jetzt neue Informationen über Menschen bekomme, die ich vielleicht so gar nicht wollte.
So, jetzt sind wir ja wieder am Anfang, lässt sich das messen, gibt es da Forschung, gibt es da schon eine passende Datenbank?
Kann man irgendwie darüber Daten sammeln und die statistisch in irgendeiner Form in ein Bild bringen, um da mal zu Antworten zu kommen?
Es ist extrem schwer.
Es ist extrem schwer aus gerade dem Grund, den ich gerade genannt habe, dass wir natürlich immer vergleichen müssen, wie ist dieser Effekt verglichen mit Menschen, die diesen Sachen nicht ausgesetzt sind?
Und sind die Menschen, die sich eben ihre Informationen im Internet suchen, nicht sowieso schon anders als die, die sie sich anders suchen?
das heißt, wenn wir wirklich jetzt hier von Kausalität sprechen wollen und von wirklichen Effekten, dann sind unsere Forschungsmethoden wirklich ziemlich arg an ihre Grenzen gestoßen.
Aber es passiert extrem viel spannende Forschung dort.
Und interessanterweise passiert dort extrem viel spannende Forschung im Kontext von großen Technologiefirmen.
Also Facebook hat riesige Research-Units, die sich jetzt wirklich mit diesen Fragen befassen.
Twitter hat große Forschungsbereiche dort.
Beide Firmen haben jetzt in letzter Zeit große Forschungsprojekte ausgeschrieben, wo sie sich wirklich die besten Sozialwissenschaftler weltweit von Unis gesucht haben
und gesagt haben, helft uns, dieses Problem zu lösen.
Wir wollen verstehen, wie unsere Plattformen die öffentliche Meinung beeinflussen.
Und es gibt spannende Forschung, die eben zeigt, dass viele dieser Effekte, die wir sehen, eben im richtigen Kontext auch verglichen werden müssen.
Und das ist natürlich …
Läuft das öffentlich diese Forschung, also ist das richtige …?
Teilweise öffentlich und teilweise nicht.
Und ich finde es extrem wichtig, dass diese Firmen da rein investieren, weil das ist ihre Verantwortung.
Was ich deutlich problematischer finde, ist, wie oft die Forschungsergebnisse dann doch nicht veröffentlicht werden oder zumindest erst mal intern verwertet werden,
das finde ich auf jeden Fall sehr problematisch.
Ja.
Aber dass die Forschung gemacht wird, finde ich extrem wichtig.
Ja gut, kommt natürlich drauf an, zu welchen Ergebnissen die kommen und was dann sozusagen mit diesen Ergebnissen gemacht wird.
Also ich meine, wenn Facebook dann feststellt, dass all das stimmt, was wir immer schon in unseren schlimmsten Träumen befürchtet haben,
welchen Einfluss die Plattform als solche nehmen kann und das ist dann das Ergebnis und dann nimmt sie diesen Einfluss auch,
dann weiß ich nicht, ob ich noch so gut schlafe.
Aber vielleicht kommt es ja auch zu anderen Ergebnissen, ich weiß es nicht.
Genau.
Naja, vielleicht kommt es zu den Ergebnissen, hat hoffentlich die richtigen Berater und Beraterinnen, die ihnen helfen, diese Probleme zu lösen.
Also ich rede jetzt mal ganz realistisch einfach, dass man natürlich hofft, dass, sollten es Ergebnisse sein, die einem nicht gefallen, dass sie zumindest zu Veränderungen führen
Ja und es ist ja auch die Frage, inwiefern die Technik am Ende auch das maßgebende Element ist?
Oder ob wir nicht auch damit rechnen können, dass quasi so die menschliche Evolution oder sagen wir mal, die kulturelle Anpassung, also die Memolution,
ob die nicht in der Lage ist, sozusagen gegen diese technische Realität und gegen diese Strukturen, die die neuen Netzwerke uns sozusagen auferlegen oder uns bieten,
je nachdem wie man das bewerten möchte, da sozusagen einen Weg drumherum zu finden.
Also es könnte ja auch sein, das ist jetzt von mir nur so ein bisschen in die Luft hinein gefragt, dass wir quasi also kollektiv neue Kommunikationsskills entwickeln,
die es so vorher noch nicht gegeben hat oder die es zumindest in dem Maße oder in der Bedeutung so noch nicht gegeben hat, das halt alles anders abzufedern.
Was weiß ich, entweder so eine eingebaute Ignoranz gegenüber Falschmeldungen oder was weiß ich, irgendwas, was halt noch nicht da ist.
Also ich glaube, wir können die zwei nicht mehr unabhängig voneinander denken.
Das ist so ein bisschen so diese Idee, dass wir die Technologie als unabhängig sehen können, ich glaube, das geht so nicht mehr.
Und das ist auch so ein riesiges Problem für die Forschung, weil wir haben Forschungsergebnisse, was sind die Effekte von sogenannter Fakenews
und die halten jetzt vielleicht gar nicht mehr, weil sich eben genau die Umgangsformen verändert haben, weil sich der Diskurs auf diesen Plattformen verändert hat.
Und deswegen glaube ich, müssen wir die zwei zusammen denken.
Also ich glaube, schöne Beispiele dafür sind zum Beispiel Finnland oder Estland, Länder, die sich schon relativ lange darüber bewusst sind, dass es eventuell Desinformationskampagnen gibt,
relativ nah an der russischen Grenze und da hat man eben schon sehr früh in die Ausbildung und in die Entwicklung innerhalb von Schulen investiert, um zu sagen,
so lese ich Nachrichten, das kann ich daraus ziehen, so bin ich kritisch gegenüber gewissen Meldungen.
So merke ich vielleicht, wenn es eine Falschmeldung ist oder wenn es eine Richtung sehr tendenziös ist.
Ich glaube, das ist was, was wichtig ist und was alle Länder machen können.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir, glaube ich, viel zu lange gedacht, dass die Strukturen, die die Plattformen uns vorgeben, neutral sind.
Und das hat sich jetzt natürlich ganz stark geändert im Kontext der US-Wahl.
Aber ich glaube, das ist auch was, wo wir einfach noch keine Lösung gefunden haben.
Das Gute ist, dass jetzt die Plattformen selber wissen, dass es ein riesiges Problem ist.
Oder dass sie zumindest ein Problem damit haben, wenn sie sich diesem Problem nicht stellen.
Genau.
Von daher kann man auch regulativ an der Stelle vielleicht einiges erreichen.
Absolut.
Ja, da haben wir jetzt einen schönen Ritt durch die Disziplinen gemacht.
Einige Fässer aufgemacht.
Einige Fässer aufgemacht und gibt es noch irgendeinen letzten Gedanken, den man vielleicht nochmal fassen sollte?
Irgendwas, was wir …?
Also ich glaube, eine Sache, die ich kritisch betrachte im Kontext der öffentlichen Diskussion um die Digitalisierung, ist, dieses extreme Schwingen des Pendels.
Also dieses extreme Schwingen von …
Verheißung.
… Liberation Technology, wir werden alle dadurch erlöst zu, …
… also jetzt gibt es Bücher, die heißen irgendwie, is the internet killing democracy?
Untergang.
Also bis hin zu, Facebook zerstört unsere Demokratie.
Und ich glaube, diese beiden Extreme bringen uns nichts, die helfen uns weder zu verstehen, was die Probleme sind, noch helfen sie uns zu verstehen, was eigentlich alles gutes passiert ist in den letzten Jahren
und wo wirklich positive Effekte für Demokratiebewegungen für uns einzelne passiert sind.
Und ich glaube, wir müssen weg von diesen beiden Extremen und müssen einfach eine pragmatische Diskussion darüber haben,
weil teilweise ist es ja auch die Angst vor Fakenews.
Ich benutze jetzt Fakenews wirklich in Anführungszeichen, ich finde den Begriff sehr problematisch.
Die Angst davor, diese Angst der externen Einflussnahme, die dann den Effekt hat und nicht die Fakenews selber.
Und ich glaube, deswegen ist diese extrem polarisierende Diskussion nicht zielführend und nicht besonders hilfreich.
Genau. Aber dafür gibt es ja Podcasts, da kann man alles klären.
Genau.
Ich sage, vielen Dank Anita Gohdes für die Ausführungen zu der Forschung im Digitalen, auch im nicht Digitalen
und der wundersamen Verquickung von Mathematik und Sozialwissenschaften.
Ich sage auch, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, das war es hier bei Forschergeist.
Geht bald wieder weiter, bis dahin, tschüss und bis bald.